let's go next to our caller from the
five-seven for area code who's calling
today from 574 hi Brittany hey Brittany
what's up um I was just wondering you
have any advice for someone whose family
is completely pro Trump
personally I'm not and all of my family
is and they're more on the abusive side
of the pro truckers Oh what do you mean
by that who are they abusing well me if
I say or do anything they come at me and
act like I'm the bad child and I'm doing
all the wrong things and supporting the
wrong things and all that oh my goodness
what state what state is this all
happening in Buddha's country Indiana
okay and so your entire family is very
much pro Trump and then you'll introduce
an alternative to that so to speak and
they will attack you yes and even if
it's like my site's extremely way more
logical like the illogical miss comes
out and then that's when the abuse of
wordage and such comes out can you give
me an example of how their how their
verbally abusing you
Oh basically you know this you know like
well you're stupid you don't you don't
know what you're talking about
it's all along the lines of you know you
don't follow the family you're not
Christian enough oh my god yeah is this
evangelical Christianity yeah kind of
like I like to refer them as the Bible
beaters not so much of the going to
church but they promote that and if you
don't go you're a bad person and when
this happens is this like parents is it
siblings cousins what like generation
relative to you is it parents mostly Wow
Wow
that's tough I mean listen it ultimately
the answer is really in you in the sense
of what do you want your relationship to
look like with these family members
right because I give you advice that
would smooth things over but to
make you feel like you're repressing
your thoughts which isn't good I could
give you advice that would be very
confrontational where you would feel
like you're getting your thoughts out
but it could ruin your relationship with
your parents so really you know I I'm
not well-positioned to tell you what how
to handle it it's really about figuring
out what is it that you want this
relationship to look like because you
know III mean at a certain point you've
got a you may have to choose do I want a
reasonable superficially reasonable
relationship with my parents where deep
down you're extremely frustrated or do
you want to risk them potentially
shunning you it almost sounds like in
order to get your points across and
nobody can answer that other than you
Brittany
yep I agree sorry to hear about the
situation I mean it really sounds
horrible yeah it's not fun but you know
I appreciate your show it gives me
smiles and makes me feel better so thank
you thanks Brittany really great to hear
from you and let us let us know how that
all how that all shakes out that's not
not a good situation whatsoever